CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is a former
homeland security adviser to President
George W Bush good morning good morning
charlie despite questions about who knew
what when right what is this doing
really doing to u.s. Russia relations
look that the temperature is pretty hot
with the rhetoric and I think the whole
purpose of Tillerson is going there is
to try and lower it's it's harder to say
nasty things to your face than it is and
you know when you have any spokesperson
do it and so I think the purpose of
tiller sins visit is to try and lower
the rhetoric and see if there's any
place where the US and Russia can work
together on Syria I will tell you the
Kremlin has doubled down right Putin's
statements they've doubled down on Assad
at the moment saying that the evidence
is faked that the you this is a
rebel-held stockpile it's nonsense and
we know it's nonsense the u.s. tried to
put the sort of lied to that propaganda
effort by releasing to classifying some
of the intelligence not all of it
Charlie there's more there but the u.s.
is trying to carefully manage this in a
way that allows them to protect sources
and methods so that they continue to
have some insight to the weapons program
the chemical weapons program in Syria
but it's pretty extraordinary as
Margaret Brennan pointed out that on the
eve of this visit the White House has
the front page on all three of the major
newspapers this morning saying to
reporters here's the intelligence about
Russia's complicity in what happened in
Syria that's right i mean Nora they I
think Russia's double down because of
course they failed right to be the
guarantor that they told the Obama
administration they would be and there's
got to be real concern in the White
House this is not the only stockpile and
they they said as much in the
declassification yesterday they assume
that there are additional chemical
weapons they've sent the message you
know the missile strike was the sort of
a first step but it's not a strategy and
so what Rex Tillerson and the
administration have to do now is build a
strategy with coalition partners to the
extent we allow this to be a us-russia
problem we diminish our leverage right
we would have to bring in our Arab
partners who want to see Assad go to put
to increase the pressure on Russia does
the US intelligence believe that Russia
knew that the Syrians were going to use
sarin gas
you know it's interesting Charlie they
were very cagey yesterday when they
released this intelligence about making
that statement it's sort of hard to
imagine they didn't though right because
the Russians were co-located at the very
base that the Syrians used to launch
this we struck one base there are six
there five other major Syrian Air Force
bases and the question really becomes if
you can bring it if you can build a
coalition and bring in your Arab allies
why can't you have them strike the other
five bases pull out the air defense
system crater that crater the air
traffic control system and command and
control increase your leverage over
Assad and force the Russians to the tape
and despite all the Russian obfuscation
do you think in the long term Putin is
wedded to keeping Assad in power you
know I don't think he cares about Assad
let's let's be honest what he cares
about is the strategic asset that is
char tues that is the deepwater port on
the Mediterranean his only one and
that's what what Putin cares about if he
could I think if you could get him a
guarantee that he'd have access to that
port absent decide might be the leverage
for Fran Townsend thanks as always thank
you